hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review uh some of your requests
is uh testing of vintage uh
audio products i have such a thing all
those
twists on it and uh it's a twist on the
dynaudio
amplifier that's been out i don't know
30 40 50 is more
and uh but it's a new take on it by a
fellow by the name of bob latino uh i
see him at every audio show sitting in
the corner soldering these boards
has a fixture always in the bay in the
major hall
and uh basically this is a modified
design with bunch of tweaks over the uh
original sd70 which i've also reviewed
if you're interested in that and you can
look on audio science review but
basically you get this uh
board over here that's the newer design
it's got this nice multi-turn
oops let me go down here multi-turn pods
in here for setting bias um and
let me take it to his website
these are sold as a kit that you put
together
uh doesn't seem that complicated to do
although probably got fair number of
parts in here on the pc board you got to
do but past that looks like just simple
uh wiring over here um he offers a bunch
of tweaks most of which are are in this
unit um one of the tweaks is this uh i
don't know if you can see it i guess you
can't see it there are a couple of
switches over here that you can switch
from pen to operation to try out
uh on this thing the uh terminals are
being replaced with modern terminals
instead of having 4 8 and 16 it only has
four and eight uh ohm taps uh that
they've brought out
um
let's see it's quite a heavy duty
machine oops
sorry almost knocked over a power cable
quite a heavy uh machine with the three
transformers in the back and uh back
breaking to move it um
excuse me but very shiny nice uh
cabinet stainless steel polished
stainless steel that's
quite nice and um
as far as the tubes this was uh uh i
think this somebody built this and then
another person bought it and the member
that gave it to me bought it from him
and i picked it up in between the two um
the output tubes are el34s
and the prima luna 12va7s are the
preamps
and
let's see a couple things were broken in
this one but i don't think it impacts
his performance the uh
uh this one speaker plug over here is
loose and and the rca connector on the
left channel was loose but unless you
really really twisted the cable uh it
worked fine i couldn't detect any
problems
um
once i put the tubes in there the bias
was way off and of course i didn't put
the tubes in they needed the order that
there was no order on them so i just
plugged them in
and uh despite what it says as far as
setting the bias to 1.56 volts this is
as i said it's a newer design and uh for
these tubes cl34s the
bob recommends 0.4 volt
bias
so i let the unit warm up
excuse me uh and set the bias
incrementally went back and forth cycled
a few times on the left cycle a few
times on the right
and then went back to left went back to
right there's a lot of interdependency
there um but once the thing was on 15 20
30 minutes it didn't seem to drift much
uh on this thing i also tested at a
higher bias there were some people
arguing with bob that
um
at least the original excuse me enjoyed
uh better performance at higher buyers
so i tested that also and i'll talk
about it in a minute
uh
let's see anything else no
uh after i set the bias i ran my
standard warm-up test by then of course
the amp was pretty warm so good news is
that it's very stable once it's warm uh
on this thing
so going to our usual dashboard of one
kilohertz uh
tone and that i adjust to be at 5 watts
we see that the gain is uh about 0.3 db
different between the two channels so
you got a little bit of a channel
matching issue
and um
that aside uh you know typical of two
tube amps and unfortunately the
performance is actually worse than the
uh original sds uh 70 uh and that's 10
db higher distortion is in the third
harmonic not the sort of classic you
know second harmonic people think is
good this push-pull design so
um it doesn't have that anyway the
second harmonic uh bias so
um and then we have tons of power supply
uh uh sp area and um you know i try to
play with the grounding it makes
absolutely no difference so this is all
bleeding from mains and power supply
into the uh amplifier and coming out um
on this i did adjust the uh bias to 0.45
volts on on one channel and uh i've got
2 db better sign ad and the channel
matching actually got better the gain
improved a little bit
i don't know what the longevity issue is
with having it to be um
you know
run a higher bias and warmer i didn't
try to diagnose that but i figured i'd
put the data out there for people want
to go tweak such things
this owner bought this in the midst of
the review of the carver crimson 275
which was a very disappointing amplifier
to test
it had this insanely high output power
despite having little transformers in
there and i measured it and in almost
all cases this version of sd70 out
performs it
um so
compared to uh you know the carver is
much better buy uh convert compared to
the original c70
i think the vintage one did better in
this regard has a sign at a 63 and we're
only 54 over here so about 9 db higher
and that's because this distortion was
90 b lower
on this thing
um as i mentioned i uh it has a
penthouse in triad mode um i went ahead
and switched to think the tribe mode and
the gain went down so be careful when
you do an a b test the volume will be
lower unless you compensate for it so
you can't do a proper a b test by just
flipping the switch the volume will
change
and
in triad mode distortion gets even worse
you're down you know you give up another
seven or eight db
i guess if you want distortion factory
the triad will be more of a distortion
factory
on this thing
i was uh i like the fact that it's
rather quiet for two vamp uh uh we got
14 bits of dynamic range and five watts
playback and at full volume it's almost
cd you know 15 bits of dynamic range so
not bad and it beats the carver by 7 db
which is nice
uh frequency response was kind of
strange no matter which tab i use on the
back and which load i put on it this
little
notch was there i don't understand why
one channel is filtering
something at 30 kilohertz and the other
one is not
but
maybe there's a wiring issue in this or
component issue i don't know i haven't
looked at the design
on this thing but luckily it's outside
of the audible band so at 20 kilohertz
where i have the cursor the two are the
same sounds the channel matching issue
so about a quarter db
uh off so your sound stage maybe just a
hair skewed one way or the other uh on
this thing so
i wish that wasn't the case but you know
as i mentioned if you muck with the bias
you can get this thing to be closer
there shouldn't be a dependency on that
but there is
um
i was impressed with that
crosstalk measurement and uh usually
even though this line looks like it's
halfway in between these a lot of
equipment even modern ones struggled to
get to the halfway point so i'd say
slightly better than average uh you know
as far as getting in here
so channel separation is quite good
multi-tone is always the bane of
existence of these high distortion abs a
lot of people say well those are all one
killers tones and who plays that music
has a lot more tones well okay this has
32 tones it just makes the situation far
worse because every tone intermodulates
with another one you get this grass at
the bottom so any detail your music
that's below 60 65 db will get lost in
sea of distortion and noise so
basically i have 10 to 12 bits of
clarity everything after that is gone so
it's like taking cd and chopping off 46
bits from it and uh and replacing with
distortion below that level uh so people
say it's good i don't think it's good
i'll talk about my listening test later
on
um
this
distortion sets in very very early on
this i think one of our tube designers
speculated that this must have very low
feedback
and that would explain why distortion
rises so quickly basically before you
mean a quarter of a watt you know you go
from being noise bound to being
distortion bound
and uh letting it go to nuts and
generate maximum power we can before
clipping over here
it generates 39 watts
so by tube standards not bad and it
beats the carver
by 10 watts so definitely proves that
the cover was under designed and
over-specced as far as what it can do
i run a standardized test where i
measure power at a fixed distortion of
one percent so the analyzer will will
iterate and change the input voltage
until they can
get one percent distortion noise in the
output and then it measures the power
usually this number is bigger than what
i where i put my cursive but this amp
clips at such high distortion that the
usable power at one percent distortion
is only nine watts anything over nine
nine or ten watts you're actually
beyond one percent distortion um and the
peak is the same problem here is a burst
over here we're feeding it and it
generates 30 more power but you still
only got 12 13 watts
so uh don't count on playing this
anything loud with this or inefficient
speakers
um switching to a uh using the 8 ohm tap
and measuring 8 ohm we get same power 40
watts uh on this thing which is uh
unusual compared to uh solid state amps
in that they usually get half the power
uh at ad rom that they do at forum so
here you get basically uh similar kind
of performance
so
um
poster text review that you see in here
which i post last night i listened to it
um and uh similar experience i've had
with other tube uh preamps uh two
headphone amps and uh standalone amps uh
i found that the
sound is kinda just loses that impact
and clarity and the dynamics and the
tightness that uh digital has it just
becomes
more muddy to my ears and worst part of
it is the bass the bass just gets flabby
and and just pop up
rather than a boom boom boom so strong
clean dynamic uh you know bass punches
just become so loose and and uh um wrong
to me it just it sounds like you have
some extra room modes that you don't
normally have and uh to make sure that
was happening i did a quick a b test i
played the uh
vta c70 first and then i switched to the
uh purify based uh
audiophonics amp that i reviewed
recently and it's just night and day now
beyond that it's just uh no amount of
power uh you can get fairly loud and i'm
listening to my infinity speakers over
here three four five well maybe five
feet so it got loud but not very loud
and if you keep cranking the volume
first you get this sort of a compression
sits in where it doesn't quite want to
get loud enough then the bass notes get
become distorted and then you hear
crackling
so
now obviously if you have extra
sensitive horn speakers or something uh
you know you'll get the louder volumes
but for everyday use and these are tower
speakers so it's rather sensitive um
that i have in my lab and uh
it just
you know i can't figure out the appeal
at all with the sound uh at some point
the engineering may appreciate that it's
something this simple jerry's that kind
of sound and music it's you know
transistor products
are just so much more complex uh these
days versus the simplicity of a handful
of uh you know active parts generate
music
but that's all there is to it now
i used to really pound on you know
performance like this but i've learned
that you know that people want to get a
tube and look at it and everything so i
let them sort of fight it out amongst
themselves on this front and if that's
the case i'd say the original sd70s is a
you know better performing one i think
all these tweaks have been made
perhaps haven't enjoyed some kind of
close feedback loop like the
measurements i'm showing
uh i suspect this design can be improved
but you know nobody's gone and measured
like i did and
you know as a result the performance of
products drifted back i'm sure some
people say sounds better
but as i explained it's just all these
distortion products to me is what makes
the sound muddy it's what
removes the impact of of notes and and
what's in your content and you know
because every time you you get one tone
you also get spray of harmonics that
come after it and so everything blends
in to becomes more homogenized i did not
hear anything euphonic i didn't hear
anything sounded better i didn't hear
more liquid
mids or more analog anything
uh
you know but you know that's me
so my ears are a lot more tuned to
hearing distortion and
and of course it decided test so maybe
if i did blind this would be different
but anyway this is not for me but you
have the data
uh it's better than a carver which costs
a lot more money and it's really under
design and poorly designed even though
that's the name carver on it it's really
a mistaken product uh it just
you know we've got 50 000 page threat if
you want to go through it but it's just
the performance is not there and it's
distortions higher just there's nothing
good about the carver other than it
looks pretty in purple or whatever color
that it was it um the original std70
that i tested like very crusty and rusty
but uh it had you know lower distortion
so you could argue if tube is good
you know well that one doesn't have as
much distortion as this so you can't say
that this is same as the you know same
characteristic just because you have
distortion doesn't mean you want to pile
a lot more in there
so that's all i have for you hopefully
you enjoy this variety of reviews that
you see from me
i probably do a vintage product once a
month or month and a half as members
send them to me
on this thing i know there are a lot of
old-timers that enjoy seeing these
reviews and
brings them back memories and so forth
okay see you in a future video bye-bye